The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This week is my
second pair of lectures.
Last week the two lectures were
about first order differential
equations, and this
week second order.
Those are the two big topics
in differential equations.
Let me start with most
basic second order equation.
We see the second derivative
and the function itself,
and we don't see yet the
first derivative term.
This is the nice case, when I
just have y double prime and y.
In general, I-- I'm taking
constant coefficients today.
Because if the coefficients
depend on time,
the problem gets
much, much harder now.
So let's stay with
constant coefficients,
meaning we have a mass, for
example, we have a spring.
The stiffness of the
spring is k, the mass is m,
and the y, the
unknown displacement,
tells us the
movement of the mass.
The classical problem.
You will have seen it before.
Because you have an
exam this afternoon,
I wanted to start with
things that-- they
are about second
order equations,
but they're still close to
the exam idea, particularly
the idea of exponentials.
With constant coefficients,
that's the fundamental message.
Exponentials in,
exponentials out.
But it's not quite
so clear when we
had first order,
y prime equal ay,
we knew that the exponent was a.
The solution was e to the at.
Now we've got second
derivatives coming in,
and it won't be so much
e to the at type thing.
Either the at was growth for a
positive, decay for a negative.
Now we're going to
see oscillation.
It's still exponentials,
but oscillation.
Things going up and down,
things going around.
Harmonic motion, you call it.
Sines and cosines.
And sines and cosines connect
to complex exponentials.
So that instead of e to the
at-- so now oscillations--
they're going to be coming
from e to the i omega t.
In other words, instead of an a,
we're going to have an i omega.
Or, if we like to
stay real, we can
stay with cos--
cosine-- and sine.
And actually, I've written
two real guys there,
so I better have
two complex ones.
And it will turn out
to be plus or minus.
There are two frequencies there.
Plus i omega, minus i omega, and
they turn into cosine and sine.
So in this case,
with no damping term,
we can stay entirely real
without creating any problems.
We can work with
cosines and sines.
The first question
is, what's omega.
What is the frequency
of oscillation.
And of course, another
similar picture
would be a pendulum,
a linear pendulum,
swinging side to
side, keeping time,
because that frequency
will stay constant.
Always I'll start with zero
on the right hand side.
Just look at these equations.
Constants there.
I'm looking for solutions.
And I'm looking
for null solutions,
looking for the natural motion
of this spring, the natural up
and down motion of this spring.
Classical problem.
Won't be brand new, but
it's the right starting
point for the full
second order equation.
It'll get a little
complicated on Wednesday,
when damping gets in there.
The formula got a little
messy, because you've
got a mass-- you've got
an m-- and a k, still,
but you also will have
a damping constant.
Then complex numbers
really come in.
Here they're optional.
So this is my equation to solve.
Because we don't have
a first derivative,
a cosine will solve that.
So let me look for-- I
could look for exponentials.
Maybe I should do
that first, look
for an exponential solution.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
And let me not
jump ahead to know
that the exponent has
that i omega form.
Let me discover it.
So I look for no
solutions-- because I
have that zero there--
no solutions of the form
e to the st, some exponent.
Plug it in.
That's the message with
constant coefficients.
Look for exponentials,
substitute them in,
discover what s will be.
So let's just do that.
This is the most basic step.
For null solutions
will be exponentials,
I substitute into the equation.
I get ms squared
from two derivatives.
It will bring s down twice.
This is just ke to the st, and
I'm looking for null solutions.
Zero.
No forcing.
So this is undamped, unforced.
Undamped, unforced.
Natural motion.
What do I do now?
Plugged in an exponential,
got this equation.
And the beauty is that
the exponentials cancel.
An exponential is never zero,
so I can safely divide by it.
So I cancel those, and I get
ms squared plus k equals zero.
The key equation-- and
it's so simple-- it's
just we're doing algebra now.
The calculus, the derivative
we took when we plugged it in,
but now it's an
algebra question.
And of course, solving
that system is easy.
There's no s term,
no damping term.
So the frequency, s, is-- put k
on the other side, divide by n.
s is-- s squared, let's say--
is k over m-- is minus k over m.
Critical point.
That tells me, with
that minus sign there,
that s is an imaginary number.
A complex number has a real
part and an imaginary part.
In this case, all imaginary.
No real part at all.
It's natural to think-- s
is the square root of that,
so I'm going to write--
everybody writes-- s,
the frequency s, is i omega.
So if I plug that in, I have
omega squared equal k over m.
i squared and the minus
1 deal with each other.
So the frequency omega-- here
is the great fact-- square
root of k over m.
That's-- yes?
AUDIENCE: What
difference does having
imaginary parts to answer
affect the oscillation?
PROFESSOR: To-- OK.
Oscillation, just
pure oscillation--
which is what we would
see here with no damping--
is the frequency, e to the--
the solution-- the displacement,
I could write-- the
displacement up and down,
y, will involve e to the i
omega t, and e to the minus i
omega t.
We've got second order equation.
Let me just go back
to that key point.
When we have second
order equations,
we look for two-- we
expect and we want
and we need two-- solutions.
There will be two.
I didn't put it
here, and I should.
s, the frequency, is
plus or minus i omega,
because in both cases when we
square, it comes out right.
So we get two frequencies,
and here they are.
So let's see how to
answer your question.
The presence of this
i is only telling me
that, essentially, I've
got sines and cosines.
That's really what-- when it's a
pure imaginary number-- I would
call that a pure
imaginary number,
there's no real part at
all-- then equally cos omega
t and sine omega t.
I can now, if I want, go real.
I can say, OK, these were
the general null solutions.
Let me put this down, then.
The null solution-- I'm
looking only right now
at null solutions-- is
some combination of e
to the i omega t and e
to the minus i omega t.
That's what we got from
plugging in e to the st,
discovering that s was
an imaginary number,
and we got these guys.
But equally-- equally--
yn is a combination
of cos omega t and sine omega t.
And maybe you'll
like those better.
I think everybody practically
likes those better.
Do you see that these guys
are the same as these guys?
The c's are a little
different because, well, we
know that we can switch
from one to the other.
We remember that basic fact
that e to the i omega t
is cos omega t plus
i times sine omega t.
You're used to maybe seeing that
omega t as theta, e to the i
theta is cos theta
plus i sine theta.
And e to the minus i
omega t, of course,
is cos omega t minus
i sine omega t.
I hope you won't think
I'm filling the blackboard
with formulas, because I'm
really just writing down--
well anyway, they're
beautiful formulas.
So if I have these guys, then
I have these and vice versa.
If I have cos--
how would you write
cos omega t using
the exponentials?
I want to just see
totally clearly
that I can go back and forth
between complex imaginary
exponentials and
cosines and sines.
So how would I, I want to
go in the opposite direction
and write the cosine and the
sine as combinations of these,
just to show if I've
got combinations of one,
I've got combinations
of the other.
Combinations of these are the
same as combinations of those.
So what is cos omega t
in terms of these guys?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
some of them divided by 2?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
If I add those two,
this part cancels.
I've got two of these, so I
have to divide by 2, as you say.
It's a half of the first
plus a half of the second.
And how about sine omega t?
Sine omega t is always
slightly more annoying,
because it's the one-- it's
the imaginary part that
brings in an i.
What would be the same formula?
How could I produce sine
omega t out of that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The difference
divided by 2i.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If I take the difference,
that'll cancel the cosines.
So I'm going to take
e to the i omega
t minus e-- minus e to
the minus i omega t.
Take the difference.
But then I've got 2i
multiplying this sine.
Up here I had a 2, but now I've
got-- when I take the subtract,
these i's are in there,
so I divide by 2i.
So this just tells me
that I can go either way.
Next time, we'll see what
happens when there is damping
and there are complex numbers
instead of pure i omegas.
We're golden here.
We've found the great
quantity with the right units.
The right units of
omega are 1 over time.
Actually the units are
radians per second,
would be the typical
appropriate unit.
Radians per second.
I'll use the word
frequency for that,
but there's another
definition of frequency,
cycles per second.
I just want to think about
steady motion around a circle.
So this tells me how
many radians per second.
And if this is 2pi-- if
omega happened to be 2pi--
then I would go once
around the circle.
If omega was 2pi, then
when t reached one,
I would be around the circle.
Let me draw a
circle in a minute.
So there's a 2pi here hiding
behind the word radians.
And in many cases,
you'll want also
a definition in
cycles per second.
So f is omega
divided by the 2pi,
and that's in cycles per second.
Full revolutions per second.
And that's hertz.
I think I misspoke last
time in confusing these two,
so let's get them straight here.
There's no complicated math in
here, it's just a factor 2pi,
but of course that
factor is important.
So a typical frequency
in everyday life
would be like f, 60 cycles
per second, 120pi radians
per second.
So I'm going around in a circle.
Now I'm ready to have
initial conditions.
This connects, again,
to the afternoon exam.
We found the general solution
with some constants, like here.
Let's keep that real form.
And now those constants
get determined
by the initial conditions.
Conditions plural, because
we have an initial position,
like I stretch it-- maybe
I stretch it and let go.
Maybe I stretch the
spring and then I let go.
What happens?
By stretching it, I'm giving
it an initial displacement.
And I'm giving it
zero initial velocity,
because I stretched
it and just let go.
Another possibility
would be to strike it.
If I hit that
mass, that would be
a different initial condition.
What would be the
initial condition
if it's sitting there in
equilibrium quietly minding
its own business and I hit it?
Then I've given it
an initial velocity,
with initial displacement zero.
So those would be the two
extreme possibilities.
Pull it down, let
go, or strike it
when it's sitting
in equilibrium.
Anyway, we've got two
initial conditions.
You see why-- y double
prime is showing up
because essentially
we've got Newton's Law.
This is Newton's Law.
Mass times acceleration is
equal to minus ky-- that's
the, with the minus sign,
and the all-important minus
sign, that's the acceleration.
That's a force, sorry.
Mass, acceleration, this thing
with a minus sign is the force,
and the force is pulling back.
If y is stretching,
the force is restoring.
Let me just go ahead
with what you know.
The initial conditions.
And I want to solve my double
prime plus ky equals 0.
So I'm still talking about
the unforced with given
y of 0 and y prime of 0.
Just think for a moment.
Could you do that?
This is the most basic
second order equation.
We know what the
solutions look like.
Let's do this one in a
box, cosines and sines.
We know what omega is.
Omega had to be square
root of k over m.
Then the equation was solved.
All I've got left
is to get c1 and c2.
All I have left is to
match-- choose c1 and c2
to match the two
initial conditions.
So let me just do that.
What are c2 and c2?
At time zero, I have to match
an initial displacement.
So at time zero, this is a
1, cosine of zero is a one,
and that's a zero.
So at t equals 0, I have y of 0.
The displacement
matches c1 times cosine
of omega t, which is
a 1, plus c2 times 0.
I'll put it in there
plus c2 times 0.
C1 cos 0 plus c2 sine 0.
I've learned c1.
And also-- what do I do next?
I want to get c2.
And where is c2 coming from?
Now I would like to know
what's the coefficient
of the-- the initial
conditions are supposed
to determine that coefficient.
It'll be that initial
condition that determines it.
y prime of 0.
The initial velocity should
match the derivative.
OK, so what's the derivative?
y prime.
So the derivative of the
cosine will be a sine.
And that will disappear
at t equals 0.
The derivative of
this sine will be
a cosine with a factor omega.
So I'll have y prime of 0
will be the c2 omega cos of 0.
Which is what?
That tells me c2.
You could do all this
without my pointing the way.
I'm solving this equation.
I have the solution in general
form with two constants.
Now I'm determining
those constants,
and cosine and sine just
determine them perfectly
because cosine is 1 and
sine is 0 at the start.
So we've got the answer.
The solution is y of t is
c1 is y of 0 cos omega t,
and c2 is-- now
you'll notice, c2
is y prime at 0
divided by omega.
y prime of 0 divided
by omega sine omega t.
There we go.
Finished.
Unforced problem solved.
Everybody in this room
could get to that point.
Let me make some
comments about that.
It's a combination
of cosine and sine.
They're both running at
the same frequency, omega.
I'm going to give a special
name to that frequency, omega,
this famous formula,
all-important.
Lots of physics in that formula.
I call that the
natural frequency,
because the next step will be
to drive the system by a driving
frequency, which would
be different from omega.
So we need to--
we've got 2 omegas.
Actually when I first
wrote the book I thought,
we've got to keep
these two separate.
Everybody has to
keep them separate.
My first attempt was to use
little omega and big omega
for the two.
I concluded after
looking at it for a while
that it was better to
be more conventional.
People had figured out
a good way to do it.
And the good way is to call
this the natural frequency
and put a subscript, m.
So all the omegas that
you see on this board
should be omega n.
I can change them all, but
let me just change it here.
I'll change omega n.
So that's omega n.
We've only got that
one omega right now,
because we don't have
a driving term yet.
So natural frequency
has the advantage,
which kind of made me smile,
that the n stands for natural,
and everybody calls it
the natural frequency.
And n also stands
for null, and we're
talking here about
the null solution,
because there's no forcing.
So I could have
subscripts on all the y's.
Eventually I'll need
subscripts on the y
to separate what we've done.
This is really yn of
t, the null solution.
Good?
Now we could take one more step.
This is a combination
of cosine and sine.
And we learned
last time that that
could be put in a polar form,
but I don't plan to do this.
Let me just say I could do it.
This would be some
amplitude, some gain--
maybe g for gain--
no, a for amplitude
is good-- times-- what is this
second optional form, which I'm
just going to write here,
say that we could do it,
remember a little about it,
but not make a big deal-- what
is it I'm after here?
I'm looking to write this
combination of cosine and sine,
which is two oscillations, a
cosine curve and a sine curve,
but with the same frequency.
Then I can combine them
into a single cosine,
a single cosine of omega nt.
But now what else have
I got in this form?
There's a phase
shift, minus phi.
Thanks.
So there's an a phi, two
constants, or there's y of 0,
y prime of 0, two constants.
Let me not write again the
formula for a or for phi,
I don't plan to do
anything with it.
It just could be done.
In other words, what
we've done so far
is just to see that the
single spring oscillates
with the frequency omega n.
That's really what we've done.
A single spring oscillates
with a frequency omega n.
Saying that makes me
think, let me look ahead
to the linear algebra
part of the course.
So where is linear
algebra going to come in?
It's going to come in
for a system of springs.
When I have another spring.
Can I draw another
spring and another mass
and another spring?
Say six springs, six masses.
Then-- and they could be
different k's, different m's,
or not.
Then we've got six
displacements--
six differential equations--
coupled together,
because the whole system
is coupled together.
So what happens at that point?
That's the point where linear
algebra, where matrices
are coming in.
You want to see what's
the point of matrices.
It's not a separate
course by any means.
It's a most necessary part,
because a single spring happens
in reality but also
systems today are coupled.
Big, actually, there
are many, many things.
You have an electric
circuit with thousands
or tens of thousands
of elements.
You have a coupled
system with many gears,
many oscillations going on.
So we need matrices
at that point.
Can I even just add one more
word about the language?
When we had-- here
we have a frequency
of motion for one spring.
What are we going to have for
two springs or six springs?
The motion will be a combination
of six different frequencies.
And so you'll see that it's
a much more interesting,
much more not so simple motion.
A combination of six
pure frequencies.
And those frequencies
are determined
from the six eigenvalues
of the matrix.
I'm just using that
word looking ahead.
We will have a 6x6 matrix to
describe the coupled system.
That matrix will
have six eigenvalues.
It will tell us six
natural frequencies,
and our solution will be
a combination of all six
oscillations.
Here, it's 1.
Here it's 1.
That spring is not there.
So the problem
we've solved now is
the fundamental, basic problem,
and I have to-- next step
is forcing.
I now want to add a force
that drives the motion.
In general, it could be
any function of time.
Calling it f of t.
So that's what I'm
going to put in now.
But in reality, very,
very, very often f of t
is also a simple
harmonic motion.
It's also a cosine.
But at a different frequency,
at a driving frequency.
So I'm going to--
the next equation
to solve is to put in cosine--
let's stay real for now--
at another, driving frequency.
At a driving frequency.
And of course, it could
have an amplitude.
But let me take that amplitude
as 1 to keep things simple.
So now I'm talking
about forced motion.
Can we solve it?
How can we solve this equation?
Let me take out the 0 or-- take
out the 0-- equals cosine omega
t.
With a different omega.
If the two omegas were the same,
if the driving frequency is
the same as the
natural frequency,
the formulas have to
be slightly adjusted.
There's still an answer,
but it's a case of resonance
and you have to look separately.
But let's say, no.
Let's say omega d is
different from omega n.
How are you going to solve this?
I have to think myself.
How do I solve that.
Let's start a fresh board.
my double prime plus
ky equals cosine
of omega dt-- or often,
I won't put the d.
I don't have to
put the d anymore.
Omega will now represent
the driving frequency,
because I've got omega
n, the natural frequency,
as the square root of k over m.
What am I looking for now?
I found the null solution.
I'm looking for a
particular solution.
I'm trying to keep the
whole thing systematic.
Null solutions are
now dealt with.
Took a little more
time than just ce
to the at for first
order equations,
because we've now got a
two-dimensional collection
of null solutions,
but we've got them.
Now I'm taking a forcing term.
So I'm looking for a
particular solution.
I'm looking for any
solution to this equation.
I'm looking for
a particular guy.
What do you suggest?
Again, it's a neat
problem because
of that particular forcing
term, a cosine, an oscillation.
So I'm going to look for yp is
some gain times [INAUDIBLE].
This is the next and,
fortunately, a highly, highly
important case, in which
the particular solution has
the same form as
the forcing term.
It's just a multiple
of the forcing term.
That's best possible.
That's best possible, is to have
the forcing term reveal to me--
the forcing term immediately
reveals a particular solution.
Once I know what I'm
looking for, what do I do?
Substitute it in.
So I substitute that
particular solution in here.
And notice everything
is going to be
a cosine, mgy double prime.
So what do I get when I
plug this in for that guy?
I want to-- you can do
it quickly, but let's
stay together and do it
together, because we can
with this case.
What happens when I plug that in
and take its second derivative?
I get the g.
And then what's the
second derivative?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We have a negative,
because two derivatives
of the cosine bring out a minus
omega d, will come out twice.
And I'll keep writing
omega d for a moment,
but then I'll give up on the d.
Cosine of omega dt.
And then k times this,
g cosine of omega dt,
equals the forcing term,
cosine of omega dt.
It worked.
This is one of that small
family of nice functions
where the solution has the
same form as the function.
Actually that list of what
you could call best possible
forcing functions, where the
form of the forcing function
tells you the form
of the solution.
That's a small family.
But it's fortunately
a very important one.
Cosines, sines are
included, and we'll
see all the other guys
that are included.
Most forcing functions
we couldn't just
assume that the solution
had the same form.
It's only these nice ones.
But cosines are nice.
So what do I do now?
Everything is
multiplying cosines,
so I just look at--
I have minus m omega
squared g-- g is going to factor
out-- minus m omega squared
and a k times g.
Let me remove that
off for the moment.
I'm canceling cosine omega,
so my right hand side is 1.
That's it.
We looked for a solution
with that simple format,
and we found it.
Now we know g, the gain.
So the solution is-- this
is g is 1 over k minus m
omega squared times
cosine of omega t.
And omega is omega d.
Omega is omega d now.
Does that look good to you?
This is the periodic solution
going at the driving.
This is what the-- this g is
the gain, the driving force.
The driving force is 1
times cosine omega d,
then that 1 gets
multiplied by this number.
This is, you could say,
the amplifying factor.
I guess frequency response
would be the right word.
Can I bring in that
word, response, again?
Response is a word
for a solution.
It's what comes out.
When the input is
this, a pure frequency,
the output, the response,
is a pure frequency--
same frequency, of course--
multiplied by that.
That is the frequency
response factor.
Notice we could write that
a cool way, by remembering
that omega squared--
that's wrong as it stands.
What have I forgotten
in writing k
minus m omega squared
in that denominator?
I forgot a subscript,
which is n.
Which is n.
This is n.
This is-- is that right?
No.
Is it?
Or is it d?
Maybe I didn't make a mistake.
Is it d?
You're seeing a kind
of critical moment.
Which is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's d, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's d.
Sorry.
But when I see this and remember
what omega n squared is--
omega n squared is
k over m-- I can
see that I can get an omega--
I can use this in here
to make it even
more interesting.
So it'll be equals-- let me
get this box ready-- cosine
of omega dt divided by-- now
I just want to rewrite that.
I want to take out an m.
I'm going to write this
as m times k over m.
m times k over m.
Safe to do that.
Now I have a factor, m,
that I can bring out.
And what is m multiplying?
That's the neat thing.
What is m multiplying?
k over m is-- omega n squared.
And this is minus
m omega d squared.
Minus omega d squared.
That's pretty terrific.
The gain is this multiplier,
1 over m, times that.
And we see that the gain
is bigger and bigger when
the frequency is near
the natural frequency.
And of course everybody has seen
the pictures of that bridge--
wherever the heck
was that bridge?
Somewhere in the
Northwest, I think.
You know the bridge
I'm talking about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Tacoma, Washington.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
Tacoma, that's right.
The Tacoma Narrows Bridge.
Right.
Tacoma, Washington.
Where the natural--
when you build a bridge,
you've built in a
natural frequency.
And then when traffic comes,
it's doing a driving frequency.
And if you haven't got
those two well-separated,
you're in trouble,
as this shows.
Or similarly, when an
architect designs a skyscraper,
there's going to be a
frequency of oscillation,
a natural frequency, at
which that skyscraper swings.
And then there's wind.
Actually I talked yesterday
to the-- by chance,
the math department is not a
very party-going department,
but once a year we let it out.
And so we had our party
at Endicott house out
in the suburbs, and
all the usual people--
that's all the professors
I know-- came, of course.
But also, there was
a really cool person.
He's the key architect
for Building 2.
You've noticed that
Building 2 is under wraps
and we're moved out.
And we move back
in January 2016.
So we've been out a
year and a quarter
and we have another year
and a quarter to go.
It's going to be cool.
And you may say,
well, who cares.
But the key point is
Building 1 is next,
and Building 1 is going to
have the same cool addition
of a fourth floor.
We're putting in a fourth floor,
which all the-- Buildings 3, 4,
5, 6 go up to four, but
Buildings 2 and 1 stopped
at the third floor.
But there's a lot of space
up there under the roof.
And they've
discovered they could
put a fourth floor up there.
Here was one interesting
thing, though.
These buildings that we're
sitting in are sinking.
You know that MIT was built
on marshy land, just the way
the Back Bay-- which
is like the greatest
idea in the history of Boston,
the Back Bay and the dam
that makes the Charles
River beautiful--
was built by bringing
in trainloads of earth
from Needham.
So whole mountains and hills in
Needham have come into Boston
and come here.
So anyway, we're sinking.
You may say something like
3/16 of an inch a year
is not something to
worry about, but now it's
been more than 100 years that
these buildings have been here.
Anyway, not good to sink faster.
So the weight had
to be controlled.
So by putting in a
fourth floor, that
put in a lot a new weight,
and faster sinking,
probably by some formula here.
Probably there.
So the weight had to
get subtracted out.
It turns out that
the ceiling, the roof
to Building 1-- Building 2
and no doubt to Building 1--
was more than a foot
thick of concrete.
Really heavy.
And some more asbestos
probably, which we don't want
to think about.
That's much reduced.
A whole lot of weight
came out of the roof.
I think they probably did
the calculation right,
so we won't get
rain coming through,
but it won't weigh as much and
the fourth floor is acceptable.
All this was a big decision
by MIT to pay for that,
or to raise money and pay
for the new fourth floor.
But it's going to be fantastic.
And it'll be fantastic
in Building 1 also.
So all that is discussion
of that formula.
That's the frequency response,
this factor to frequency,
omega d, or omega,
is this factor.
I guess I should say
something about resonance.
What happens when that
formula breaks down?
When the driving force
equals the natural frequency,
then we're dividing by 0,
and something is different.
The formula isn't right anymore.
What enters in the formula-- let
me just tell you what enters,
and then we'll see it
in a simple example.
When I have this repeated
thing, two things are equal,
what tends to
happen is a factor,
an extra factor, t, appears.
So an extra factor, t, will
appear in the case omega n
equal omega d.
The solution, y,
will be some factor,
I'll still call it g-- no,
I don't want to call it g,
let me call it a.
There'll be a factor, t,
times cosine of omega t.
So in this case, there's
really only one frequency.
We're driving it.
So the oscillation grows.
As you know, when you
push a child on a swing,
the whole point of
pushing that child
is to push at the
natural frequency.
You wait for this swing
to swing back naturally
and you drive it again
with that-- at that--
maintain that frequency.
And of course you
see the amplitude--
the child swing
higher and higher.
Presumably you stop pushing
before disaster for that child.
But that's a case of resonance.
And it's what happened in
the Tacoma Narrows Bridge,
and there was nothing
to-- nobody stopped,
traffic just kept coming.
The movie is amazing,
because there's
one car that shows up after
it's already swinging wildly,
some crazy person
still driving across.
And you might think, OK,
that's ancient history.
But you know the
bridge in London,
the pedestrian bridge, the
Millennium Bridge-- it's just
a walking bridge
across the Thames--
a big feature of modern London,
and it had the same problem.
It was swaying.
People could not walk across.
They couldn't keep
their balance.
So they had change it.
So it's not trivial
to anticipate.
So now we've solved it-- we've
solved the the null equation
with no force, and
we've solved the driving
force equal to a cosine.
And of course, we
could do a sine.
What other driving
force should we do?
I think we should
do a delta function.
I think we have to understand
the fundamental solution is
the case when, if
we can solve it--
there's always this general
rule, if we can solve
with a delta function,
that will give us
a formula for every
driving force,
because every function is some
combination of delta functions.
So if we could do
it with a delta--
really the great
right hand sides
are-- well, cosines
and sines I'll
include as great
right hand sides.
Those are the
exponentials in disguise.
So the great right
hand sides are
really exponentials at
different frequencies and delta
functions.
Delta of impulses.
So now I want to find
the impulse response.
That's the next--
that's really a job.
At this point, in these
last 20 minutes when
I solve my double prime plus ky
equal a delta function-- well,
what I was going to say was
I'm now taking you to something
that you won't see on
the exam this afternoon.
But maybe you will.
Delta function, right hand side.
I haven't seen it yet.
Or I haven't looked recently.
You won't see second
derivatives, I guess.
So what is it?
So now this is of the
form with an f of t,
a very special f of t.
And that very special f of
t makes that extremely easy
to solve.
That's really my
point here, is it
it's going to be a
cinch to solve that,
and we practically
have done it already
to solve that with
a delta function.
And the reason is
sort of physical.
We have here our spring.
And what am I doing
with that force?
I'm hitting the mass.
I'm striking the mass.
Let me say, and I'll write
it on the board, the point I
want to make about this.
That point is that this
equation with a delta function
force starting from 0-- say,
y of 0 equal y prime of 0
equals 0, let's give
it starting from rest--
it starts from
rest by hitting it.
And that hit, that impulse,
is in no time at all.
It's not stretched out.
It's hit over one second.
So this has the same solution.
This is the beauty.
This is why we can
solve it so easily.
Same solution as-- let me write
it and see what you think--
as my double prime
plus ky equal 0.
We know how to solve those.
With-- it's still, when
I hit it-- when I hit it,
what happens in
that split second?
In that split second, it
doesn't have time to move.
It doesn't move.
It still has y of 0 equals 0.
But in that split second,
we've given it a velocity.
We've given it a velocity.
And that velocity
will be y prime.
The initial velocity is 1--
because here I had a 1--
over an m.
We have to have the units right.
So here's a point, and
we will stay with it.
We'll come back to
this point next time.
Maybe the first thing
for you to take in
is the fact that it's
such a nice thing.
We have this equation with
this mysterious delta function,
and I'm saying that
the solution is
the same as this
equation with no force,
but starting from a mass.
I'm tempted to take an
example to make this point.
Let me take an example where the
whole thing is a lot simpler.
y double prime equal delta of t.
I've taken the spring away, so
the k is gone, the mass is 1.
What's the solution to y
double prime equal delta of t?
If we concentrate on this
example, we're good for today.
So my point is the
same solution as-- now,
what's the other problem?
I'm just repeating here, but
making it simple by taking k
equals 0 and m equal 1.
So the same solution as y double
prime equals 0, with y of 0
equal what, and y
prime of 0 equal what.
I just wanted to repeat
here what I've said there,
and then we'll solve it and
we'll see that it's all true.
If I look for a solution to
y double prime equal delta
starting from 0-- this
was starting from 0--
if I say that's the same
as this, what should y of 0
be here?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero, right.
It hasn't had time to move.
But in that instant,
what happened to y prime?
It jumped to 1.
That's right.
Exactly.
Now just solve that
equation for me.
Solve this example for me.
Suppose y double prime-- yeah.
Here we go.
What's the solution if
y double prime is 0?
What are the solutions to
y double prime equals 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Constant and linear.
a plus bt, right, have
second derivative 0.
Now what's the solution that
starts from 0 that kills the a
and has slope 1?
What's the answer
to that question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: t.
t.
The solution to this
equation is a ramp.
It's zero everything in this
course, is zero up until time
0.
At time 0, in this example,
all the action happens.
Everything happens.
And what happens is it
gets a velocity of 1,
and the solution
is y equal to t.
y is 0 here, of course.
At that point, that's the
key point, t equals 0,
right there-- it gets a slope.
We don't have a step function.
There's no jump in y.
The jump is in y prime, the
y prime the velocity jumped
from 0 to 1.
That's exactly-- I think when
I introduced delta functions
and drew a picture.
What is the derivative, the
first derivative, y prime,
for that guy?
Let's just review, because this
is what we've seen already.
The first derivative is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] step.
PROFESSOR: A step.
And the second
derivative is delta.
The second derivative of this is
the first derivative of a step.
The derivative of a step is 0
everywhere except at the step,
at the jump when it jumps to 1.
So that's the solution
in this example.
And now to end the lecture,
let's solve it in this example.
Again, let me just say-- why
do I like this forcing term?
Mathematically, I
like it because, if I
can solve that guy--
as we're doing,
we are solving it-- if
I can solve that one,
I can solve all forces.
Over here, I could solve when
I had a very happy f of t,
a perfect f of t, where
I could guess the answer
and push through.
Now with a delta, I can
build everything out
of delta functions.
That's why I like
it mathematically.
Why do I like it physically?
Because it's a very physical
thing to have an impulse.
That happens in real
time, in real things.
And by the way, let's just,
before I write down any more
formula, what
would-- I would like
to be able to solve it
for a step function.
[? Heavy thud. ?] I would like
to be able to do that one.
I'm going to have
to erase something,
or I'll write it right
above just for the moment.
I would also like to
solve my double prime plus
ky equal a step function.
So I would call the solution,
y, the step response.
And what would be a
step function start?
A step function start would
be like turning a switch.
Suddenly things happen.
That's forcing by a step, so I'm
looking for the step response.
And how do you think
these two are related?
I look at the relation
at the right hand sides.
What's the relation of
this step to the delta?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One's a derivative.
PROFESSOR: One's a
derivative of the other.
And we've got linear equations.
So the right hand sides.
The step response, y step,
and the delta response,
y delta-- I'll use a
different letter for this
because it's so important.
One is the derivative
of the other.
The great thing about
linear equations
is we have linear equations,
differentiation, integration.
Those are linear operations.
The step function is just
like a steady-- anyway.
I was going to-- I won't--
is the integral of the delta.
Step function is the
integral of the delta,
so the step response is the
integral of the delta response.
I guess to finish the
lecture, why don't we
solve this problem,
which looks tricky
because it's got a delta.
Instead, we'll
solve this problem,
which doesn't look
tricky at all.
It's exactly what we
started the lecture with.
Zero forcing and some
initial conditions.
So let me just
finally make space
for the big deal
from today's lecture,
which would be the fundamental
solution with a force
by a delta.
I'm just going to write
down the answer when
you tell me what it is.
What's the answer to that?
What's the solution
to this second order
constant coefficient
unforced equation
with those initial conditions?
We probably had it here.
I may just have erased it.
But now let's get it.
So y is y delta.
This is the impulse response.
y of t-- and I'll give
it later another name.
So here's a perfect
review question.
What's the solution
to this problem?
Everybody remembers-- what
are the solutions, what's
the general form for the
solution to the equation?
I'm reviewing today's lecture.
The solution to that
equation looks like what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's a cosine
and a sine, right.
And then how much of a cosine do
we have and how much of a sine
do we have?
The initial condition will
tell me how much of a cosine
we have.
And what's the answer?
None?
No cosine.
This condition, this
initial velocity,
will tell me how much
of a sine we have,
because the sines are the things
that have initial velocities.
So it would be a sine
of-- the sine of what?
Square root of k over m, right?
omega nt, right?
And what's the number?
What's the number so
this has the right-- let
me write again what I want.
I want y prime at
0 to be 1 over m.
What's the number
that I put in there?
I've got something, its
derivative, at zero.
This is some number-- I'll call
it little a for the moment,
but I want to find
out what it is.
Are we right?
Yeah?
I think we're right.
Yeah.
The derivative is at zero, so
I just plug that into here,
take the derivative at zero--
of course that makes it
a cosine, which will be 1-- but
it also brings out that factor.
So a times-- well, that
factor will be 1 over m,
and that tells me
what a has to be.
Well, this is omega.
So a is-- this is
omega a equal m.
This is 1 over m omega.
And that's omega.
Sorry I'm erasing
stuff which I-- this is
the formula I'm after.
Sine omega t over omega.
I think we're good.
Are we?
Yeah?
Yeah.
I'll come back to
this in-- Wednesday
is my day to move
to damping terms.
I've intentionally stayed
with undamped equations
here, because you're thinking
about that level of equation.
Damping is going to
bring in new stuff,
and that should
wait till Wednesday.
Shall I recap today?
I'll just recap today,
and then we're done.
Today started with
the unforced equation.
We solved it by assuming--
by not thinking ahead,
just assume I have
an exponential,
because the beauty
of exponentials
is, when I plug it in,
the exponential cancels.
And that told me that
s was pure imaginary.
It told me that it had this
form, e to the i omega t.
And there were two s's.
Two possible s's,
plus and minus.
I get to make a little comment
about this example here.
What was omega?
What's the natural
frequency in this problem?
frequency here?
I guess this is a case where--
what's the natural frequency?
I guess this is a case where m
is 1 and k is 0, is that right?
This does fit into that pattern,
but it's a little special.
This is a case where
m is 1 and k is 0.
So what's the natural
frequency in this?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
Zero.
This is a crazy
case of resonance.
It's a case in which the natural
frequency and the driving
frequency, say in this--
I'll have to do it here--
this simplest of all equations
is, in a way, special.
It's a case when the
natural frequency is zero
and the driving frequency
is zero and they're equal.
And what happens with resonance?
What's the new
formula, the new term
that comes in with resonance?
It's t.
You saw it happen
for this example,
and we didn't have to
use the word resonance.
We knew that we had a ramp.
We just used the word
ramp, not resonance.
But this is a case of resonance.
When omega n is zero
and omega d is zero.
And the factor t up here.
Anyway.
Just that small comment there.
And now, just going
back to the recap.
The recap was, we
tried exponentials.
We learned that they
were pure oscillations.
We realized that we could do
cosines and sines instead,
and we did.
And we took off.
We got the formula.
Then of course the-- so this
is section 2.1 of the book.
And it goes through all
those steps carefully.
Section 2.2 of the book tells
us about complex numbers,
and section 2.3
brings damping in.
So that's what's
coming next time.
So the recap again.
We found the null solution, we
found a particular solution--
oh there's just one
comment I want to make,
and then I'm done.
Where was our
particular solution?
Yeah.
This was our
particular solution.
Here's my comment.
Suppose I want to solve
this basic equation starting
from a given y of 0
and a y prime of 0.
I'm going to do it in
two parts, I think.
I've got the null
solution, and I've
got this particular solution.
Now here's my point.
If I want to get y of
0-- how shall I say this.
You can't just put together--
it's an easy mistake
to make-- solve
the null equation
with the initial
conditions and then
add in the particular solution.
You'd think, I just
followed all the rules.
But this particular solution
that you added in has a-- at t
equals 0, it's not zero.
So you have to change.
So the correct thing,
the correct yp plus yn--
let me make that point.
Just a warning.
So in words the
warning is, remember
that the particular solution
has some initial condition--
in that case, g-- and
then that is going
to affect the right
null solution.
So again, y is y null
plus y particular-- plus y
of particular-- so it's some c1
cos omega nt plus some c2 sine
omega nt plus this particular
guy, g, cosine of omega dt.
All correct.
But now, put in the
initial conditions.
y of 0 is given.
And what do I get on
the right hand side
when I put in t equals 0?
I get c1 here.
What do I get when I
put t equals 0 in there?
Nothing.
What do I get when I
put t equals 0 in here?
g.
So it's not c1 equal
y of 0 anymore.
That's the easy mistake
that I'm correcting.
When you put in this
particular solution,
it has an initial value.
That initial value is
going to come in here.
So c1, then, the correct
c1 is y of 0 minus g.
End of story.
Just don't be too quick to just
add the two pieces and think
you can do them
completely separately,
because you're
putting them together.
And then you have
to put them together
in the initial condition.